esse produto natural não é apenas um
aliado devido à suas características
antivirais e também antioxidantes mas
também tem um papel fascinante em como
interagimos com o ambiente ao nosso
redor inclusive no que diz respeito ao
mosquito da dengue pessoal estudo sugere
que o consumo regular de própolis pode
alterar a nossa exalação através do suor
liberando compostos ativos como flavonas
e vitamina B conhecidos por suas
propriedades repelentes naturais contra
o mosquito transmissor da dengue uma
pesquisa que foi conduzida ao longo de 5
anos na Amazônia demonstrou que o
própolis pode ser um meio eficaz de
prevenção mantendo Esses mosquitos a uma
distância segura de nós além de suas
qualidades preventivas a própolis Verde
em particular se destaca na luta contra
a dengue tanto na prevenção quanto
tratamento suas propriedades
antiinflamatórias tornam uma forte
aliada no combate aos sintomas da doença